classic boozy ratchet yeah sexy moody
nasty yeah hey guys my name is paris
brows and i play v in one up my name is
dj mausner and i'm playing diane my name
is madison baines and i play lily i'm
lolita molina and i play jenna i am
taylor zakhar perez and i play dustin
i'm steven joffe and i'm playing ricardo
my name's nicholas coombe and i play
owen my name is hari neff and i play
sloane in one up today we're playing a
game of who's who in our cast
who's most likely to forget their lines
i'm sitting next to her
forget her lines i barely know her that
didn't make any sense yeah it's me
me paris
paris
uh
where are we going from
oh back it up okay wait what was the
line okay
all right the person most likely to
forget their lines is probably me
because i improvise a lot and and then i
don't remember anything i said taylor's
not the most likely to forget his lines
but he does something really cute when
he clubs a line he made fun of me
i forgot my line once it was because my
mouth didn't want to do what the words
were doing he'll be like
and then he'll start the line again and
i just think it's so cool stevie is
legit in love with taylor who is not i
was like
and then they made fun of me like i was
in high school musical
paris paris has the best tick-tock
dances she's always dancing on set do we
think paris that's tick-tocker she's
like
i i don't do the dances yeah
well if we're talking like hear up me
yeah i nailed those tick-tock dances i
don't know i think it might be me oh
yeah maddie 100
i think i'm good at like being funny
with them but i can't really do it i
don't look sexy i don't look cute like
nasty yeah wait do you do tick tock
ticks no just making sure i don't know
you know gotta have all the sag award
nominee no just kidding
i'm kidding
the best gamer nick
oh thank you i'd say the best gamer is
either stevie potentially myself
i think paris is probably the best dj
because every time i look over just so
into it and knows exactly like what
they're doing and i'm just like
i think hari is the best gamer because
she's always talking about it i feel
like you're the best gamer yeah
probably me
i logged my isolated child hours playing
those video games not for nothing here i
am
in a video game movie
i made it
i think taylor is the best gamer and
just the best
who's the most competitive
i would say me i have to win
paris does not back down that's one of
her best qualities i'm pretty
competitive yeah but i think that hari
might be too taylor
i was gonna say me yeah he might be like
number 84 on the call sheet now but he's
coming
oh signed number three thank you i'd say
stevie oh yeah i think stevie is the
most competitive but always has us
laughing competitive for best comedy
definitely between him and dj they're
always trying to one-up each other
i'm honestly gonna say that i think i'm
the most competitive and i won't hear
otherwise
the best trash talker dj dj yeah dj yeah
dj yeah dj bowser definitely dj
it's just the stuff she comes up with on
the top of her head my god is it the
funniest thing ever she thinks quicker
than anybody else i've ever met she just
comes up with
the funniest
no one's ever beat her and no one can
she's the sweetest person but when it's
time to talk on screen
dj's she's in it to win it
yeah so what
who's most likely to know the best cheat
codes you
probably
oh yeah i'm a cheater
who's most likely to play a prank on set
i would say leeda because she's
mischievous taylor and they would all
heart
they both could do a good team prank
yeah kyle our director stevie yeah he
knows it he loves it us together i can't
pull pranks they make my stomach turn
really
yeah you know because someone always
cries
most sarcastic is definitely me i will
drop some really dark wheelchair humor
to you
if someone says something normal like
hey we're gonna walk this way i just
have to shoot them a look
and they instantly don't want to talk to
me anymore it's so good is it me or
stevie you are the most sarcastic it's
me yeah it is
you
i'm a very dry sarcastic but like big
energy stevia dj kyrie's got bite when
she wants to yeah i'm not sarcastic i'm
a sag award nominee
make sure you check out one up coming to
a screen near you
you